the average wage gain for an immigrant
coming to the united states is a
four-fold increase and that person's uh
wages and that's because that person is
more productive here in the united
states because we have economic freedom
uh we have some political freedom and as
a result that allows people to be more
productive mass immigration is not
compatible
with the goals and characteristics of a
modern society in a way that wasn't
necessarily true 100 or 200 years ago
again it's not because the immigrants
are somehow inferior to your grandma who
came from sicily or anything like that
it's that we have changed fundamentally
[Music]
to episode 139 of the michaela peterson
podcast i'm michaela peterson i have a
headset on because i am backstage in
boston at one of my dad's shows and
these are very difficult to like figure
out how to get on and off with all this
hair so i'm keeping it on and this is
the time i have to do an intro so
this is an opposing views episode
opposing views is where i bring on two
experts
with opposing views on a generally
contentious subject
alex narasta and mark cricorian came on
to discuss immigration
alex narasta is the director of
immigration studies at the cato
institute and author of several books
including the most common arguments
against immigration and why they're
wrong
my second guest was mark krikorian an
expert on immigration and the executive
director at the center for immigration
studies an independent nonpartisan
research group established in dc in 1985
to provide fact-based immigration
research
quick shout out to
these bad boys carnivore crisps
we have a code
in the show notes but these guys are
literally feeding my dad and i on this
tour
feeding us
i cannot recommend them enough it's just
meat and salt it's one of the only
things i can eat this packaged thank you
carnivore crisps enjoy this episode
alex narasta welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
sure so i am an immigration policy
expert working at the cato institute
which is a washington dc based
libertarian think tank and primarily i
do original immigration research that
gets published in peer-reviewed academic
journals and policy white papers here at
cato i also write for more popular
publications like major newspapers and
on blogs
and i try to work with policymakers here
in washington dc to produce a better
immigration policy
so would you
say that
on this side of the opposing views are
you pro-immigration are you
anti-immigration
i'm very pro-immigration
okay so that kind of uh i saw that
you're from the cato institute
libertarian think tank i've talked to
other people from cato institute and for
some reason my initial view was
this guy's going to be
more right wing or anti-immigration
so
that's where i started from anyway but
you're not you're pro-immigration so we
should get into why you're
pro-immigration
yeah so i think the main reasons there's
uh there's several reasons but i think
the main one is that it's extremely
economically beneficial
for americans and for the immigrants
themselves to liberalize and allow more
immigration into the united states so
when you take a look around the world
the average wage gain for an immigrant
coming to the united states is a
four-fold increase in that person's
wages and that's because that person is
more productive here in the united
states because we have economic freedom
we have some political freedom and as a
result that allows people to be more
productive
but unfortunately we have a very strict
series of immigration laws that make it
impossible for the vast majority of
people who want to come here legally to
do so and that restricts americans
ability to hire and otherwise deal with
these people
another reason why it's important i
think is part of our sort of uh
cultural uh heritage here in our civic
heritage in the united states and we're
not the only country in the world that
has a strong immigrant tradition right
you have canada australia new zealand
other countries but here in the united
states we have a strong tradition of
allowing people to come here legally to
work to live to eventually become
americans and this has contributed
mightily to the prosperity and
individual freedom and liberty of this
country just to give you an example
if immigration in the u.s had stopped in
the year 1800 today there would be fewer
than 100 million americans living in the
country and currently there are 330
million and i don't think there's any
person who would claim that the united
states would be a wealthier freer
uh stronger uh country if we had if
there were fewer than 100 million of us
uh here today
and then i think also additionally as
being sort of a beacon
of liberty and of these sort of
classical liberal values in the world
it's very important to have a place
where folks around the world who agree
with those values
can come here can live freely
can practice that and it's in the
national interest of the united states
so this is not charity you know this is
not something nice that the u.s
government does for other people but it
is basically them getting out of the way
allowing people to want to come here to
help themselves to be part of our
country and it makes americans better
off in the long run as well
okay so you mentioned
bringing people in that share our values
so i think part of the
more i don't more conservative argument
would be that there's an influx of
immigrants they don't have very much
skill they're taking away jobs from
americans and they don't share our
values and that's kind of watering down
i guess american freedom
so
you have a response to that does any of
that seem accurate well that's that's
that's an argument made by a lot of
folks who are you know skeptical or
opposed immigration and it's the same
argument that's been made
um since the 1700s in this country it
was made about the irish the germans
uh chinese polls russians jews etc back
in the 19th and inner century and
earlier and it's the same arguments that
are made today about current immigrant
groups and when we take a look at the
evidence that simply isn't there so for
instance like some of the most uh the
most well-known economist
who studies the impact of immigration on
wages for instance uh in the united
states is george borjas from harvard
university and what he found is from
1990 to 2010
uh immigrants to the united states
um increased the wages of native-born
americans uh by about half a percentage
point overall
and the only potential area where there
was sort of a slight decline in wages a
relative decline in wages uh were those
who americans who are high school
dropouts who are about eight percent of
the u.s population and that's the most
he's a well-known economist george
borjas but that's the most negative
finding
in the entire academic peer-reviewed
literature another series of economists
giovanni perry
and gian marco aviano they found that
the wages of all americans went up by
about the same about half a percentage
point but that native-born american high
school dropouts wages rose roughly by
about 1.1 percent and that gap that
negative 1.7 to 1.1
is where this entire debate is among
economists who study this and this
doesn't take into account all the other
big effects on the economy the enormous
amount of additional productivity for
instance like immigrants are more than
twice as likely to start businesses as
native born americans uh more than twice
as likely to patent as native-born
americans and and to innovate as
native-born americans are and so that
that sounds a little weird to people
right like why would an enormous number
of new immigrants not lower wages right
like that's kind of weird right you have
this big increase in supply
but the price doesn't go down and
there's a lot of answers to that but the
most obvious one is that you know
immigrants are people
and they buy things and by buying things
it increases demand and so by having
more demand that that general effect of
having that more demand and an increase
in supply
when the economy reaches equilibrium
again is that wages are slightly higher
in the united states
okay
so we're only talk so this entire
argument really only comes down to
people who don't have a high school
degree
that's basically if you're looking for a
negative economic impact on the wages of
americans from immigration it's
basically about high school dropouts in
the united states who are about eight to
nine percent of the adult
population but even then there's vast
amounts of disagreement
over that and it's important to clarify
when i say these wage increases or
decreases these are not an absolute
wages this doesn't mean like a paycheck
goes down it just means that relative to
other education groups
they haven't grown as much so when you
take a look at like wave yeah so it's
kind of like this funky econ thing like
i have a background in economics and
this is basically the only way
that you can really measure it so the
wages of these folks have gone up over
these time periods it's just that
they've probably gone up a little bit
slower than they otherwise would because
of the large amount or large number of
immigrants who have come in
and are we even sure that that's the
cause
so
we're pretty sure there are lots of
reasons why rage wages are growing lower
our wages are growing at a slower rate
for lower skilled americans you know one
is technology has changed a lot
so
it's just there's higher returns of
scales uh higher returns to your labor
if you have more skills if you're more
educated the economy is changing you
know it's not like the 1950s anymore
when anybody can get a job in a factory
because now to work in a factory you
have to have a ton of skills
so i think it's more due to a factor of
the change in economy and we actually
see that in places like japan which led
in very very few immigrants the same
wage dynamics are playing out there as
they are in the united states and that's
highly suggestive evidence that there is
just a bigger shift in the economy and
immigration really isn't playing that
big of a role in it
interesting
okay cool
what about then the concern that you
have people okay say what's happening in
europe at the moment in some areas in
europe where there's an influx of people
with a different religion coming in
and that's changing what's going on in
some of these cities parents for
instance and i probably come at this for
more of a right-wing angle
but that's what i've like read and what
i've seen so i think that some of the
concern about immigration lies in oh are
we going to have an influx of people
that like i said don't share american
values and then is that going to end up
being a problem in the future
right so that's that's an important
point i actually wrote a whole book
about this because it's i think
potentially the most devastating uh
counter-argument to my position so the
book is called wretched refuse
and it's published at cambridge and and
the idea is
and and i also want to say you know
immigration is different in different
countries right they have different
issues and it depends on where the
immigrants are coming from partly
it also depends on the institutions in
those countries so to give you an
example
immigrants in europe usually have access
to an enormous amount
of means-tested welfare benefits
immediately after coming into these
countries and in the same token these
countries have a lot of labor market
regulations that make it very different
difficult for lower skilled immigrants
to get jobs to get like a a step up
right so you have this bad situation
where you have a high unemployment
situation for immigrants and they get a
lot of welfare benefits which makes it
less likely that they work and then
they're sort of by law kind of
not unintentionally but unintentionally
through these welfare benefits and
public housing sort of like segregated
and housing complexes in parts of the
city where they don't interact um with
natives in that area so i think it has
more to do with that whereas in the
united states
you have a situation where
there's very little access of new
immigrants to means-tested welfare
benefits you basically have to work like
the first thing that you do as an asylum
seeker in the u.s is you have to get a
job or as a refugee you've got to get a
job in europe there are laws where it
says if you're an asylum seeker a
refugee you can't get a job sometimes
for several years
because they're worried about you
competing with native born people and as
a result that has all these effects but
you're not interacting with natives
there's not really that opportunity to
economically assimilate there's not an
opportunity to culturally assimilate and
that also affects the types of people
who are going to go because the type of
person is going to go to a country where
you have to work and pull yourself up is
different than the type of person who's
going to go to our country where they
can live on uh welfare and these other
uh issues for a long time and then
there's also just like a cultural
difference right like in the u.s and
canada and australia you know these are
immigrant societies where their identity
is not based on uh blood or borders or
culture nearly as much as in the united
states canada and australia where we
have this idea of what it means to be an
american for instance it's not based on
like the color of your skin or your
blood
or or anything like that but it's much
more sort of a creed it's much more of
an ideological or civic identification
and the nation-states of europe that's a
little different right it's based on
your membership of these tribes right
can you claim like a you know a descent
from the frankish tribe that settled
france in the year like 500 can you
trace your ancestry back in some ways to
like the ancient gauls and verse and get
tricks that's just much more tied into
it so i have a cousin who is uh half
iranian and half norwegian and this is
this is just an anecdote but she lives
in norway and she's when she says she's
norwegian norwegians correct her and say
no you're something else
whereas here
if you know an american were to say i'm
not an american i'm like iranian
americans are kind of offended to go no
you're american
and that's just like a very opposite
thing it's starting to change a little
bit in europe because they are becoming
more immigrant societies but that's
something that can only really happen
once the definition of what it means to
be german or french or norwegian sort of
grows to encompass uh the immigrants and
their descendants
that's very interesting okay this is why
i like these these episodes this is good
yeah it's it's really like a super power
actually it's it's one way
um one of many ways i think in which the
united states is quite exceptional and
it's something you know i think canada
does well i think australia new zealand
all these countries do i think pretty
well
on this idea and it's something that the
rest of the world
is starting to learn and pick up on and
they're going to have to adopt um
no matter what happens in the future
yeah
okay let me see
what about the issue right now like what
percentage of immigrants right now in
america i don't know if you know this
number off the top of your head but are
illegal
about 25
really
yeah so
there's about 45 million or so
immigrants in the united states
and somewhere between about 10 and 12
million are currently uh illegally
present in the united states um about
half of them entered legally actually
and overstayed their visas so they
became illegal immigrants that way the
other half uh crossed the border
uh or otherwise entered unlawfully and
stayed
around 12 or something like
um well around 10 to 12 million about 25
okay
wow okay and just to put that in
perspective right like that is a vastly
greater percentage
of the immigrant population that's
illegal in the us than any other country
in the world vastly greater
yeah vastly and is that because of the
border between the us and mexico
so i think there's two reasons one of it
is we're basically the only developed
country that borders a developing
country
so if you take a look at europe like the
land borders for instance i mean they
basically all border peop countries that
are pretty developed uh by comparison
you know canada borders the united
states which is developed australia
doesn't have a land border neither does
new zealand um so that's i think part of
it so there's this enormous wage poll
like your sort of median mexican worker
coming to the us who has a high school
degree can expect a three-fold increase
in income by coming here
and that takes account of and that
includes cost of living right so that's
an enormous economic pull
for these folks to come here and to walk
from central america and i think the
second reason is people don't realize
how difficult it is legally for the vast
majority of these people to come here i
mean if you want to come here on a green
card and you are not related to an
american or another legal immigrant and
you're not highly skilled and you're not
one of a few refugees or asylum seekers
there is basically no way for you to
come here on a green card like there is
no green card category for a low-skilled
worker
unless you're related to an american and
so like if you apply these laws that we
have right now these immigration laws
back in time
virtually no americans would be here
today because very few of us would our
ancestors would have qualified to come
here legally
do you think that's reasonable given the
population of the us right now
no no i mean what's what's interesting
right is the us does have 330 million
people it's the third most populous
country in the world but it's also a
very large country and so when you take
a look at the sort of number of people
per square mile in the united states uh
we could have
um you know five to six times as many
people here and we'd have the population
density of some western european
countries you know that are very you
know wealthy
stable industrialized successful
countries so i don't think there's
really any sort of uh limitation in
terms of land area or space or economic
system i mean one of the great things
about
free markets and capitalism and i don't
pretend the us is a free market uh
utopia or anything like that but we do
have relatively more free markets than
most other countries in the world but
one of the great things is having more
people come in who are producers who are
consumers who are innovators who are
entrepreneurs or just want to spend
their money here you know renting and
living
that increases the size of the economic
pie and that increases the amount of of
wealth and productivity right it's not
like a redistribution there's not a
fixed supply of wealth that's being
distributed around they actually grow
the and increase the amount of wealth
and that's one of the you know one of
the secret powers of uh free markets and
it's one of the reasons why
the world is so much more so much
wealthier than it is today it's than it
was you know for our ancestors and just
the relatively recent past and so
there's really no limitation on this
except what the market puts a limitation
on i mean if there's no demand for
workers if there's no demand for
foreigners to come here and start
businesses then they won't come but
there's obviously an enormous demand
which is why people break our
immigration laws uh because our laws
make it so difficult to come i mean one
of the things that people don't realize
about american immigration laws
is that compared to other oecd countries
other rich countries in the world
america's laws are more restrictive than
most of them
so western european countries canada
australia all allow in many more
immigrants as a percentage of their
population than the u.s does so for
canada it's like three times as many
annually
compared to the united states as a
percentage of the population australia
it's about five times as many
switzerland at six times as many so the
u.s you know i think we're rightly proud
of our immigrant ancestry and our
history and our our values in this sense
but when you take a look at current
american laws
you can't come away with any impression
except that it's highly restrictive and
much more restrictive than other
countries that don't even think of
themselves as having a proud immigrant
heritage
it's interesting talking to you so you
have the view i think that you bring
more people in and then hooray we have
more helpful people here more smart
people to help improve the country and
the other side is you bring more people
in and you have a whole bunch of
unhelpful people you have to take care
of
i think that's a fair characterization
right and and i think this comes down to
just like a basic
difference in how you view these things
like i don't view immigration as charity
and this is something where i disagree
with some of my left-wing friends who
are pro-immigration you know the way
they talk about is oh immigration is us
helping the world or us helping people
it's like it's not helping it's the us
government getting out of the way
so that immigrants can help themselves
and so that americans can also benefit
by working with them and selling to them
and hiring them so it's a mutually
beneficial and voluntary
exchange right it's like in the same
sense where if you know i talked to my
neighbor who's a native born american
right and i say hey i'll hire you a kid
for ten dollars to mow my lawn
well what's the difference between that
everyone realizes that's like mutually
beneficial and positive but all of a
sudden if i go and ask somebody from
mexico hey do you want to come over and
work for me and i'll pay you ten dollars
to mow my lawn all of a sudden that's
like viewed as bad
and there's really no economic reason
why that is there's no good economic
justification for that you know there
might be other effects right if that
person is a criminal yeah that's bad and
i am in favor of course in blocking you
know criminals national security threats
people who have serious communicable
diseases from coming to the u.s
but other than that there's no good
economic reasons to to stop that
i guess the concern there would be
for some reason if you're paying an
illegal immigrant then the money they're
earning isn't staying in america maybe
it's being shipped off somewhere else
so some of that definitely is right
whether it's an illegal immigrant or a
legal immigrant or something i mean a
lot of them do send a good amount of
their money uh back to their home
countries but based on how sort of the
international economics works those
dollars have to also come back to the
united states in the form of american
exports to those countries right so an
american might hire let's say a worker
in the united states to work at his
business that immigrant might send half
of that money back to his home country
let's say mexico and then his family in
mexico uses that money to buy better
education
or to buy a better house etc but then
that money as it works its way through
the mexican economy eventually makes its
way back to the united states in the
form of americans exporting like ipads
or cars back to mexico right so and it's
important to know like that initial
wealth right like that initial creation
of that wealth of me or that american
hiring that mexican immigrant creates
goods and services that would not have
existed otherwise
and as a result that's what makes us
wealthy right what makes us wealthy is
not like the dollar number on our bank
accounts or anything like that but it's
what you can do with that money right
and we have access to goods and services
that's what makes us wealthy you can
mess around with the numbers all you
want but so long as we have access to
houses and healthcare and cars and all
this great stuff material stuff that
does improve the quality of our lives
that's the measure of what makes us
wealthy and what immigration does just
fundamentally is it's more people who
are workers and entrepreneurs who
increase the supply of stuff
and services that americans want that
the immigrants want and that makes us
all wealthy
or wealthier than we would be otherwise
okay
i can wrap my mind around that
so you said compared to europe
there's a complete difference in the you
said means tested welfare benefits what
does means tested mean exactly
so means tested
welfare benefits are welfare benefits
for people who are poor
um
which is sort of different from like
entitlement programs which are like
social security or medicare which are
for people who are elderly um you know
so they sort of just qualify for it
based on oh they worked a certain number
of years and they're of a certain age so
they get these benefits meanwhile means
tested benefits are for people who are
in poverty and they are they are
intended to help people get out of
poverty or at least make poverty um you
know more um i don't know tolerable for
them
okay
i didn't realize that i should have
thought about this probably before this
podcast but i didn't realize that
different countries bring in different
sets of people so it's not that everyone
is specifically looking for skilled
labor some people are doing it like you
said out of charity and so you said
right now
when people when the america brings
immigrants in you know what percentage
of that is specifically skilled workers
so when you take a when you take a look
at sort of the um there's different
portions of the us immigration system so
if you look at green cards and green
cards a lawful permanent residency that
it means that if you're here for five
years you don't commit any crimes
then you can become a citizen if you
want to it's what we sort of
traditionally think of like immigration
and there's basically four major
portions of this
seventy percent are family members
about five percent are what are called
diversity visa which is basically like a
lottery for 50 000 people who are
um you know they're they have some
skills but they're not coming for their
skills necessarily there's another about
five percent or so who are refugees and
asylum seekers who are fleeing
persecution
and then you have somewhere around seven
to ten percent who are
specifically
coming to the united states because they
are high skilled workers and when you
take a look at the numbers this is
somewhere around 70 to 80 000 per year
um some people will say it's 140 000 but
that's the total number of people who
can get these green cards for high
skilled workers but that includes their
family members because you have to count
their young children and spouses against
that but for the workers themselves it's
about 70 to 80 thousand
there are temporary visa programs called
the h-1b
for high-skilled workers
they come in for three to six years
they're able to work and get some
extensions sometimes and we allow in
about 85 000 of those types of people
per year to work temporarily and those
programs and uh that's for firms what's
interesting is you know i work at a
non-profit research institution
there's an exception to the h1b
that says
there's no numerical limitation
on the number of people who can come in
and work at non-profit research
institutions
so what's interesting is people like me
and people who work at universities i am
more exposed to foreign high skilled
competition
than just about anybody else in the u.s
labor market
to put that in perspective so
interesting why would that be
specifically for non-profits
specifically for nonprofits who are
doing research so that was just an
exception that was built into the law in
1990 and the idea was you know we don't
want to limit
the sort of temporary hiring of skilled
people who are doing research because
you know congress is like hey research
is pretty good we want more research it
helps uh we don't want to artificially
limit that
and so this is sort of was expanded to
the idea that like non-profits who do
research
um should have you know access to these
people now there's a whole bunch of
regulations in there you know you have
to pay a minimum salary of sixty
thousand dollars per year you have to
check a bunch of other boxes it costs
thousands of dollars sometimes upwards
of ten thousand dollars in legal and
government fees to do this right so it's
not like you just get the pick and grab
anybody you want right it's highly
regulated um but when it comes to that
right people will um people like myself
are the most exposed to this foreign
competition and a large a fairly large
number of my colleagues are either
currently h1b employees or enter the
united states initially as h1bs and then
they will eventually be able uh they're
eventually able to get um a citizenship
in the united states
yeah well so i'm speaking sorry speaking
from a position of experience right like
i i do face this type of like
competition it's not like i'm in an
ivory tower right where i'm saying oh
you little people you have to compete no
i'm not saying that at all this is
something this is something that i live
uh day in and day out and it's something
that i think has made me a better um a
better employee at least i hope so and
it's something where i've i've i've
gained a lot of professional uh
acquaintances and colleagues who have
made me just a much
better and more productive employee as a
native born american
what about the argument that
an increase in immigration increases
crime is there any truth behind that
so we've taken a look at this americans
uh have studied this i've studied this
going back over a century there have
been numerous government commissions
that have taken a look at this the
academic evidence is is clear and
consistent that um immigrants in the
united states
um and this is specific to the united
states i just want to be clear that
about that are much less crime prone
than native born americans much less
likely to be incarcerated much less
likely to be convicted of crimes the
native born americans much less likely
to be arrested um that and that goes for
uh legal immigrants and interestingly
enough it goes for illegal immigrants as
well
so
that kind of makes sense to me though
because if you're already here illegally
the probably the thing you want to avoid
most is getting arrested
absolutely because
if you get arrested for a crime and
you're convicted of a crime and you're
an illegal immigrant you serve your jail
sentence
and then on top of that you get deported
so it's like a double punishment ooh
right so so it's like okay i came to the
u.s
i got three times higher wages
if i commit a crime i'm gonna go to
prison i'm gonna lose those years of
wages and prison is terrible
and at the end of it i'm going to be
deported back to my home country
and my income is going to fall by you
know two-thirds or 75 percent
so that's an enormous disincentive and i
think also another way to view it right
like even when there wa weren't
deportations in the united states in the
19th century there were hardly any
deportations in the early 20th century
too it's also i think the type of person
who decides to immigrate
is different than the type of person who
doesn't
the type of person right and this is
something like when we're talking about
immigration from from muslim countries
or other places going it's not the
average person from those countries who
come it's not like a random grab bag
it's people who decide to leave and
those people are different they're
thinking about the long term for
themselves and their family
they're concerned about their sort of
upward mobility they're planning ahead
they're probably more cosmopolitan and
tolerant to begin with they don't really
care that much about living in the
society where people speak a different
language or have a different religion
they're just like less concerned about
that than other people from behind and
those people i think are just generally
much less likely to want to commit
crimes than native born
americans are now this data may differ
between countries of course
this is one of the things to take
account of this is
uh i'm just talking about the united
states in general
um
but the problem is european crime data
are
awful i mean awful i've spent a lot of
time looking into the details of
european crime data and they do not
differentiate in many countries between
you know native born criminals
foreign-born criminals
just to give you an example in many
european countries if you're an
immigrant and you become a citizen they
count you in the same category as
native-born people
for crime and that makes it hard to
figure out right but in the united
states we keep that all separate
because people have been worried about
crime and immigration forever here so we
have the data and we ca we categorize it
um
you know and and one of the criticisms i
get right is well you don't know about
illegal immigrants necessarily but one
of the things i was able to find out is
on u.s states
u.s states is where most criminal
prosecutions are because most criminal
laws are on the state level um and 49
out of 50 american states do not keep
data on criminal convictions or arrests
by immigration status they don't but one
state does
it's a great state the great state of
texas
they keep this data it's a great state
to study it has the second highest
population of illegal immigrants of any
state in the country it borders mexico
it has republican government for the
last 27 years so there's no reason why
they would hide or obstruct this data in
any kind of way and so when you take a
look at that
uh you see that the illegal immigrant uh
criminal conviction rate is 37 percent
below that of native-born american
and it even works out that way when you
take a look at specific crimes like
homicide uh it's about 25 below native
born americans you take a look at sex
crimes it's below you take a look at
property crimes it's below and then
legal immigrants are even lower than
that they're about 60 below the native
born american criminal conviction rate
and that is something um you know i wish
native born americans uh had a criminal
conviction rate as low as illegal
immigrants this would be a much safer
country if that were the case
wow
okay that's really interesting i don't
think i knew that
that's a huge difference
gigantic i mean it's it's it's gigantic
and this is something where government
commissions going back over a century um
and a lot of these commissions in the
past were put together by american
politicians who are opposed to
immigration so they're trying to come up
with justifications for trying to close
the border yeah the one thing they and
they said you know all this stuff about
immigration was not true but the one
thing that they all agreed on was that
immigrants whether it's italians or jews
or russians mexicans chinese anything
much less likely to commit crimes than
native born americans
okay okay so then here's another
question going back to
skilled workers do you think it's
reasonable that it's only seven to ten
percent of immigrants that are let in
that are skilled should that be
dramatically
increased
yes so i think a lot of the so i think
overall the numbers should be increased
but um if we were to just increase the
number of skilled workers i would take
that deal in a heartbeat
the thing that is interesting about the
u.s immigration system is that basically
it's an employer-driven system so the
employers
select high-skilled immigrants and then
they sponsor them so the employers know
like the workers work it's not
necessarily the government saying they
have to be this way or that way you know
they have to have this skill not that
skill it's the employer figuring that
out and that's a pretty good system for
selecting
sort of these unmet these uh
unmeasurable characteristics of workers
who are really going to succeed so i
would love to increase that number
dramatically i mean i think if you get a
degree from an american university and
you're a foreign born student you should
have a green card immediately you should
be allowed to stay in work start a
business if you want to in the united
states there should be i mean i don't
think there's any good reason for a
numerical cap on skilled immigrants who
want to come here to the united states
and even more and even more insane
there's no entrepreneur visa
if you want to come here and start a
business
there's no visa for you you can't do it
and that's crazy like why would we have
that
what about the
okay so i'm canadian right and i'm
planning on staying in the us because i
don't want to go back to canada because
canada's scary right now
but
what we've been looking into is
there's an entertainer visa so that
that's what i'll that's what i have at
the moment an entertainment visa so
that's easy but
i i heard about something called an e1
visa i think which at least
i thought that that was a business visa
that might be that you're allowed to bri
like move a company that's already made
into america
maybe it's just that but an e1 visa
definitely lets you do something
business related have you heard of that
yes so there there's a bunch of
different visas where uh there's a
couple different views where you can
sponsor yourself as a high skilled
person if you're sort of exceptional
but that's not specifically like if you
wanted to come here from canada
and you're like hey i got this business
idea us is the only place i can do it um
there's not a visa for that now there's
something called an investor visa
where if you have a million dollars and
you want to make an investment in the
united states then you can do that but
it's highly regulated and it's basically
how that works is you basically have to
lump your money together with a bunch of
other people who have a million dollars
on this visa to build like a hotel or
something so it's not like you can come
here and start like a tech firm right um
and it's so there are ways to get around
this with different visas there are ways
to sort of massage it there are ways of
being sort of exceptional on the oh
visa for instance for exceptional
abilities uh the first like eb-1 visa
you know you you can have like
exceptional abilities and you can come
here but it's not specifically uh for
starting the business it's just that you
can
but if you have like a great business
proposal and you're like i got funding
like million dollars like seed funding
sorry you're out of luck that's not a
visa that exists wow even if you have a
source of funding from americans
yeah from americans so what they can do
is somebody can start a business in the
united states
and then they can hire you as an
employee
or they can bring you in in different
ways but if you want to be like
the founder who works you know 22 hours
a day
building a business from scratch and you
want to come here and that's all you
have is that idea and people who believe
in you and want to fund it sorry
so you have like people who work on h1b
visas which you have to work for an
american company they're high skilled
people they have business ideas they
work in silicon valley they work all
over the country they want to start a
business
they can't do that because you can't
employ yourself and sponsor yourself on
an h1b visa
wow yeah that's harsh i can see
potentially why that was put in
so that people starting businesses had
to be american but it's harsh if you
if you're a very talented person you
want to start a business or
yeah and i don't and i don't really
understand the economics like um if
you're uh in the united states i think
we would want to attract you know
foreign businesses and entrepreneurs to
start businesses here um in the united
states i mean one of the one of the
great things about the tax cut in jobs
act which was um you know signed by
president trump was that they changed a
lot of the rules like the corporate tax
laws and some of the other laws to make
it easier for people to get financing to
have um you know to keep more of the
profits of their firms
uh but then on the same token so it's
like an acknowledgement like we want
firms and move here we want them to
invest in the united states we want them
to create job opportunities for
americans and others oh but we're not
going to create you know we're not going
to let them do it directly by coming
here as entrepreneurs
yeah yeah
that's tricky
okay
well that was very interesting i don't
think i think i covered the main
arguments is there anything you think i
missed
i think one of the things people are
really worried about
is um i think there are two things one
is sort of the the chaos
you know i think people see chaos along
the border
and they see chaos with illegal
immigration
and that makes them become more
skeptical of immigration overall yeah
definitely
and
i understand that perspective right like
i i
ordered
understand
of liberty
but the reason why people cross the
border illegally
is because for almost all of them there
is no way for them to do it legally
and if we want people
to respect the laws
the laws need to be respectable
they need to be enforceable they need to
take account of economic realities
because the one thing we know
is that when law because in conflict
with reality reality always wins
always we see that with prohibition we
see that with mass mandates we see that
with everything across the country and
our human experience so what the way
that we diminish chaos
along the border the way that we shrink
this black market and i all in favor of
shrinking black markets is not by more
enforcement it's not by building higher
fences or walls or hiring more border
patrol agents or doing interior
immigration enforcement it's by making
it possible for more of these folks to
come here legally to work legally to
work in the legal market and to do so in
a way that can be regulated because the
government cannot regulate black markets
it can only regulate illegal markets but
the first problem is
immigration in the united states is so
restricted and so complicated that it's
impossible to do that um you know one of
the most common saying by law professors
about this topic
is that the inca of the the uh
immigration laws
are the second most complicated portion
of american law after the income tax
and if you've ever dealt with the irs
you know that's super complicated and
super hard right so if we want to reduce
chaos we have to avoid the temptation of
cracking down
through enforcement and instead go the
route of a little bit of liberalization
let's allow some more people to come
here legally so that we can get control
over the over the situation and that is
what's going to work
and
i i think the second issue that a lot of
people are concerned about is sort of
like cultural assimilation you know do
immigrants and their kids integrate and
assimilate to american cultural norms
and the evidence on this is very
positive when we take a look at research
from jacob vigdor and other economists
who study this
on issues of language religiosity civic
participation family size income
education etc
immigrants overwhelmingly by the third
generation so that's you know the
grandchildren of the immigrants
themselves are indistinguishable from
native born americans who have been here
longer and this has been the general
finding for a long period of time some
immigrant groups assimilate more quickly
you know first generation the immigrants
or the second by their kids some take a
little bit longer and maybe third the
fourth generation but it's going very
well and one of the best ways that it
happens is actually through inner
marriage
that jump starts it right so like just
to give you a personal anecdote like my
um
my paternal grandparents are iranian
immigrants the united states
so my father was born here so he's
second generation
um and um he married a woman my mother
who um whose ancestors go back several
generations and as a result like i don't
know anything about iranian culture
right i i don't speak farsi
i'm not a muslim i have never been there
i have no interest in it i know probably
a little bit more about the history than
some people right i don't even like the
food that much it's just okay
and that's like a pretty
like ordinary
normal
unexceptional
tale
of immigrant assimilation like my father
uh you know bless him i love him he
claims to speak farsi
he speaks it like he's five years old
with a wisconsin accent
and uh it's hilarious so when you take a
look at like third generation hispanic
immigrants in the united states these
are the grandkids of a hispanic
immigrant who spoke spanish
78 of them are english only speakers
22 percent claim to be bilingual
but i bet they speak spanish about as
bad as my father speaks farsi
and zero percent claim to be spanish
only zero percent that's crazy i guess
that makes sense because even if i look
at like my
ancestry so all my great grandparents
were immigrants so is back that far but
i mean we're like canadian right
and my parents were certainly canadian
and my grandparents maybe had a tiny
tiny bit of the language but not really
it it is pretty quick in north america
at least
from my anecdotal experience
and that's the general experience right
you know i think we look back at
american history or canadian history or
whatnot and we have this idea at least
when i was learning history you know the
irish came in the 1850s and 60s
and we're reading about all these
problems and then we turned the page in
the history book and it all worked out
fine but when we turned that page that's
70 to 100 years
that passed
and what's really good is taking a look
at the current rates of assimilation of
immigrants it is virtually identical to
immigrants from over 100 years ago and
so the pace of assimilation the gaining
of education the gaining of experience
the self-identifying as being an
american
the religious traditions the family size
all these measures that really really
measure matter it's the same and when
you take a look at surveys about say
like patriotism you know how much do you
love the united states do you think it's
the best country in the world um
immigrants either have the exact same
opinions about patriotism as native born
americans or they're slightly more
patriotic and i think part of the reason
is
they understand that the places that
they came from
are not that good so it's easy for me
like when i was a kid once i was
complaining to my immigrant grandfather
about something in politics right like i
was upset that the republicans didn't
cut budgets enough uh in the 1990s and
he's like yeah alex you know that's
something to be upset about and i
understand you're mad about politicians
lying but no matter what you want to say
about it this is a lot better than iran
let me tell you
like i can't argue with that
huh
okay
okay well alex
that was enlightening and interesting if
people want to find you online where
should they go
so i think there are two sources one is
at the cato website that's
cato.org
and the other is on twitter and that is
at alexnerasta
all one word on twitter and you can find
all of my work uh on those two websites
i'm also on youtube and everywhere else
so just google me and google kato and
you'll find all of our work
great and that's alex n-o-w-r-a-s-t-e-h
on twitter yes
got it okay thank you very much for
coming on
thank you for having me
this episode is brought to you by paleo
valley 100 grass-fed beef sticks paleo
valley is unlike other companies in the
market they're committed to making
high-quality clean products free of
problematic ingredients and free from
farming practices that harm the
environment
their products come from small
family-owned farms right here in the usa
and their cows are never fed grains or
antibiotics i personally can't eat them
because i can't eat spices because i'm a
bubble person whose body explodes at the
site of pepper and exaggeration but not
really but these guys ingredients are so
clean so amazing there are no
preservatives fillers just 100 american
100 grass fed and finished beef from
domestic regenerative farms and organic
spices they're great it's a super easy
way to lose weight it's just switch your
snack to something like this and the
weight will come off i swear you can
help your body and the environment by
trying paleo valley's high quality
protein today just head over to
paleovalley.com
and enter code mp for 15 off your first
order that's paleo valley.com with code
mp for 15 off your first order
mark cricorian welcome to my podcast
glad to be here thanks for having me
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do i run the center for
immigration studies i'm executive
director i've been doing this longer
than i care to remember i got my
master's degree in
international relations
um didn't get hired by the cia but
that's okay actually it worked out
better um
and i kind of
dumbed into the immigration
issue but
um once you get you know the bug once
you get bitten by the immigration bug
you never let it go so i've been running
the center since
1995.
and uh you know i'm a writer and editor
and i sign the checks and do all of that
kind of administrative stuff as well
so if you could sum up your view on
immigration as in too many immigrants we
need more
immigration is bad immigration is good
what's the short form the
short answer is
immigration is too high but why
the problem is that
immigrant mass immigration is not
compatible
with the goals and characteristics of a
modern society in a way that wasn't
necessarily true 100 or 200 years ago
in other words the immigrants really
aren't all that different yes some of
them come from different countries but
that's not really the important
difference the important difference is
us
we have a post-industrial knowledge
based economy we have a welfare state
technology shrinks the world which is a
good thing in a lot of ways but also
complicates assimilation so
all of the concerns people have about
immigration
really are all just different facets of
the same thing they're kind of like that
image of uh blind men feeling different
parts of the elephant and they don't
realize it's all the same elephant well
it's the same kind of thing if you're
worried about whether it's security or
assimilation or
um you know welfare use
the economy effect on employ on workers
it's all the same thing
immigration
is was something that 100 200 years ago
in a
pre-modern conditions was still
frankly you know created a lot of uh
controversy and tumult and problems for
people we were able to work those
through
much more easily than we are today and
again it's not because the immigrants
are somehow inferior to your grandma who
came from sicily or anything like that
it's that we have changed fundamentally
okay and
we have most definitely changed
fundamentally but how do we know that
we're at the point where we should be
slowing down immigrant versus 100 years
ago given all the space in america
well uh i mean space doesn't really
count because immigrants don't spread
themselves out half an inch thick across
you know see the shining sea
they're moving into you know the same
places everybody else lives so
uh and you know even in open spaces i
mean this is a sort of separate argument
but i mean not a separate argument it's
part of this broader argument we value
things like uh you know access to nature
preserving open spaces and what have you
and you know the more people you add
inevitably you're gonna be cutting down
more trees and paving over more
uh land and you know to some degree
that's just part of what human
civilization does but
immigration is driving that in a way
that
is different today because we are as
john kennedy said when he wrote the book
nation of immigrants we've moved past
the
stage of uh you know settling and
pioneers and or you know covered wagons
and all the rest of that we're now a
settled
mature society
and you know we have the largest number
of immigrants uh ever we're about we're
at about 47 million foreign-born people
now obviously our population is much
larger too but the percentage
of foreign-born people in our population
is just almost at the record level it
reached before
immigration was reduced in the 20s
and you know it's um
when you've had enough to eat you you
take a break
and we need a pause at the very least to
enable
the new people and the people who are
here
to
knit together to work out the
um the effects on workers on wages and
what have you because
if you get one batch one large batch of
immigrants that will eventually the
effects of that person on wages of those
people on the wages
and job opportunities of americans will
eventually work themselves out but what
we're doing is taking in more than one
million
people from overseas every year
so basically
we need a breather is really what it
amounts to and that breather
doesn't mean no immigration it just
means less immigration and i can go into
detail on that if you want more
sort of what my outline would be but we
need a breather
so that we can
you know catch our breath as it were and
then we can reassess in a generation or
so what it is we want to do with
immigration going forward
so the guy i just spoke to who was an
economist he said that you bring more
people this his view just kind of wasn't
right
yeah okay yeah you're familiar with him
yes that's good
uh but his so then you're probably
familiar with his view but for the
audience his view was basically the more
people you bring in particularly skilled
labor the more jobs are created the more
money gets spent and overall it's just a
positive good for society
yeah you know i mean i actually would
prefer to go even step a little further
back from that argument i'll get to that
argument of his as well but
the basic difference i have with the
libertarian perspective that
nerasta uh from cato uh articulated is
much more fundamental than
just the question of economics because
the perspective that alex represents
is that everyone in the world has a
right literally a moral right to move to
the united states
with the certain exceptions we might
make for terrorists and what have you in
other words everybody can come except
those few
that we identify as not being allowed to
come
the way i look at it and this is frankly
most regular people's point of view is
that nobody has a right to move here
but we make exceptions for particular
people we do let in so either everybody
gets to come in and we make some
exceptions or nobody gets to come in and
then we make some exceptions for those
people who do get to come in that is a
basic
difference of values and opinion
you've really got to get past that
before you get to the point of arguing
what the effect on workers is going to
be
um but the f there's no question that
more people make the economy bigger
uh you know bangladesh has a bigger
economy than belgium for instance but
nobody would say that bangladesh is
better off than belgium
uh the fact is that
um
the one of the points of immigration
policy
is to protect
american workers but most specifically
those who
are less able
to
thrive and prosper
in the kind of dynamic modern economy we
have whether it's people who have less
education people just aren't that bright
there's always you know half of people
are below average whether it's people
who are
recovering addicts
um
ex-cons trying to clean up their act and
start a new life anybody that employers
would kind of rather not hire
is harmed by immigration the people who
benefit
are frankly people like alex and you and
i who have college educations and we
earn reasonably good wages and
immigrants aren't really competing with
us
but
as an american
in thinking about
immigration policy
i need to take into account not only my
bottom line
whether i'm going to be able to hire
servants cheaper or what have you but
rather
the concerns of all of my fellow
americans
and you know those people who are
um you know sort of at the bottom rung
for whatever reason
of the um economic ladder are people who
deserve our special consideration an
immigration policy
is a torpedo aimed at their
life opportunities
hmm
okay this is a very no wonder you've
been stuck in this topic for so long
it's really interesting because you're
you're weighing the benefits to
different people right so your your
position is america americans even if
they're less able to work but especially
if they're less able to work they need
to be taken care of properly and they
shouldn't have people from other
countries kind of usurping that position
making their life more difficult
yeah because
immigration is just like any other
government policy it creates winners and
losers it has costs and benefits
and
to put some numbers on those costs and
benefits i'm not going to
bore people too much but the national
academies of sciences did this
magisterial report where they looked you
know is hundreds of pages long they
looked at all different aspects of this
issue and on the economics the
conclusion they came to
is that
importing
immigrant labor does in fact create
a
economic net benefit
to the country the round numbers then
this was several years ago so it will
have changed but round numbers they said
about 50 billion dollars in extra income
extra earnings
for americans overall and so that sounds
like a lot i'd take half of that and be
satisfied
but
when you sort of figure out remember net
is the plus and the minus put together
and then what's the result what they did
is they looked at how do you get that
number
and they said
immigrant labor
uh creates
increased earnings for the people who
benefit from that labor amounting to 550
billion dollars it's a lot of money
even for a congressman that would be a
lot of money but
it comes at the expense of people who
compete with them who lose 500 billion
in earnings so just to sort of spell out
the math again roughly speaking 550
billion plus
but 500 million minus for less skilled
workers and others and so you add those
together you end up with a net benefit
of 50 billion dollars again not anything
to
um you know to ignore
but the question is really a moral one
is it right to engage in that kind of
reverse robin hood government policy and
i just think it's wrong
wouldn't it benefit a society as a whole
though to operate in the way that you
and as harsh as as it sounds bring in
more skilled people and then reduce the
number of less skilled people i mean
overall if that improves
society is that not a net benefit
what are we doing with the less skilled
people are they going anywhere
uh apart from the moral question
um
where are they going what are we paying
them off with welfare to sort of here
take your opioids and here's your check
and your ebt card and leave us alone
we'll have the police come if you cause
trouble that's just wrong i mean i don't
want to live in that kind of society
uh and
you know the the other thing this
national science the national academies
of sciences report found
because what we were talking about is
the economic benefit just the sort of
dollars and cents from earnings and
wages
the other thing they looked at was uh
government services
and what they found is that that entire
benefit of roughly 50 billion
is totally wiped out by the extra social
service costs
that we have to pay because poorer
people they're working but
they you know in a modern society a
person with a sixth grade education is
not very likely to be able to earn
enough money to feed his own children
so the taxpayer
does it for him and about half of
immigrant headed families use at least
one federal welfare program it's not
because there's anything wrong with them
they're not you know plotting to get
food stamps um you know
nobody's sitting in guatemala saying boy
i want to get my hands on some american
food stamps they're coming here they're
working they may be working two jobs
but because they're a mismatch because
they're 19th century style workers
coming into a 21st century society
even though they get jobs they're not
gonna those jobs aren't gonna pay very
much and congress can pass all the laws
it wants about
minimum wages and what have you fact is
you can't pay somebody more than the
economic output they're creating and so
a poorly educated person immigrant or
american just isn't going to earn a much
and isn't going to be able to support
himself and his family in a way that a
civilized society like ours thinks at
least there should be a minimum
so taxpayers are going to do it
and i'm not against a social safety net
i'm a conservative personally i think it
should be more tightly run it should be
more responsible but it's not going
anywhere and it shouldn't go anywhere
and as milton friedman said you can't
have
open borders and a welfare state
now milton friedman and other
libertarians wanted to get rid of the
welfare state and open the borders
okay well we're not getting rid of the
welfare state and even if you wanted to
go and do that first then call me and
then we'll talk about immigration
okay
what if what if immigration looked more
like
not bringing in any
unskilled workers and only bringing in
the skilled workers sure it's a good
question um
there's uh two parts to that first is
uh this
most people who want to immigrate are in
fact less skilled because
once you're
you know living a reasonably prosperous
stable satisfactory life in your own
country
why would you pick up and move somewhere
else some people do that but it's not
generally a mass phenomenon that's
number one number two
it depends you remember uh
bill clinton said uh it depends on the
meaning what the meaning of the word is
is
in that notorious uh interview of his 25
years ago well
it depends on what the meaning of skill
is what do you mean by skill do you mean
somebody who can read and write do you
mean someone with a college degree from
uh you know a third world community
college or do you mean albert einstein
and um
the higher you set the bar for skills
the smaller the number of people who
could qualify so i'm completely in favor
of
genuinely best and brightest on the
planet immigration
but humanity doesn't create that many
einsteins
every year
so um
a small number of genuinely top people
on the planet in their fields
i'm all for that's not that many people
and
one more twist to that
interestingly enough
skilled immigration actually can create
assimilation problems which people
wouldn't expect because almost all
skilled immigrants wherever you sort of
draw that wherever you set the bar of
skills somebody's gone to college in a
foreign country they probably have some
english even if they're not native
speakers even if they didn't major in it
they probably know some english so
skilled immigrants
are going to be more likely to speak
english they're more likely to be
acclimated to urban life you know
they're not they're not living on dirt
floors and huts you know what i mean
these are people who at least know the
basics of modern life so in that sense
you'd figure well they're probably
more likely to be able to assimilate and
in those respects that's true but
interestingly enough and we found out
this in earlier waves of immigration
if people are coming
already educated here they've gone
through a school system a socialization
process in their own country they have
developed
a national identity
in a way that frankly peasants
haven't in other words they've gone and
learned about how you know the sort of
the glories of their nation and how
they're part of this national enterprise
and then they come here
and they may fit in as far as getting a
job and driving on the right side of the
road but assimilation real assimilation
is a psychological and emotional process
do you adopt this new country
as your people
and that's just frankly less likely to
happen
with people who are highly educated
whereas if you get for instance a mayan
speaking
person from the highlands of guatemala
doesn't know much spanish frankly let
alone english but also
doesn't think of himself
in a as a member of a nation in a modern
sense he likes his village you know his
region maybe but not a nation
that's where we could come in
and and have in the past
nationalize americanized to those people
so they keep their
village traditions and cultural
practices and cuisine and what have you
but patriotically become americans we
saw that 150 years ago the problem of
course is that our schools are not doing
that very well at all they're teaching
american kids and immigrant kids to hate
america so
um anyway the point is that skills
um changing immigration to skills is not
some kind of silver bullet that fixes
everything
this is very interesting okay
this is great so then do you know the
statistics behind one of one of the
concerns i've heard from more
conservative people are
more immigrants equals more crime you
know the statistics behind that no
that's actually not true um
and this is something um i mean it's i
won't say it's the opposite or anything
neresta tries to sort of flip that
argument and say it's the other way
around the fact is the data is not very
good but it is pretty clear that
immigrants themselves are not uniquely
more likely to be engaged in crime the
reason the issue comes up and and people
kind of
who who you know
look at this regular folks they confuse
things is that
those immigrants who do commit crimes
need to be booted out of the country
and the left is
actively trying to prevent that and make
sure that illegal immigrant criminals
are able to stay so the issue is not
that illegal immigrants are criminals
it's that those illegal immigrants who
are criminals
need to be identified and removed from
the country and sanctuary cities the
whole point to a sanctuary city is to
protect illegal immigrant criminals
however many if there's one illegal
immigrant who's a criminal that's
obviously one too many that person needs
to go
um and that's the issue it's not that
immigration itself
is some kind of unique contributor to
crime the one place
that um
that is kind of an exception
is organized crime
and the reason that's true is that
um criminal organizations don't have
courts and contracts and nobody's
enforcing the rules there needs to be
some kind of internalized code
that would
cause you to stick to whatever the rules
are of that criminal organization
and
being
a foreigner in a country in other words
if you're if you're sicilian moving here
you're sticking together and agreeing to
those rules and operating by them among
yourselves so that organized crime
among immigrant groups actually has a
unique advantage whereas if it's
americans and there's americans involved
in organized crime but
um it's not the same thing because the
same bonds of loyalty fear of betrayal
and the rest of it don't exist because
you could always hop on a bus and move
to seattle or something and start over
again whereas that's hard to do
uh if you're a member of
a um a a sort of tighter knit immigrant
group in a foreign country and this
isn't i'm not even talking about just
today that's true today with chinese or
central american organized crime but it
was true of russian organized crimes
sicilian what have you in fact there's
this whole book on immigrant organized
crime and the first chapter of it i
forget the title of the book but the
first chapter of it was australians in
san francisco apparently and i'm talking
way back you know in the 19th century
were
in organized they were dominating
organized crime there at least for a
while so
that part of
immigrant criminality is real but when
you look at crime overall statistically
immigrants aren't especially likely to
be criminals
okay interesting so say we cut down on
immigration what do we do about the fact
that apparently a quarter of immigrants
are illegal
yeah about a quarter of immigrants are
illegal and you know i'm kind of a
squish on amnesty
um i'm open to the idea of
fixing an old problem sort of starting
fresh
but only if
you fix the problem that created this
illegal population in the first place in
other words
the approach we've had all along and
this was from the 1986 amnesty the big
amnesty that president reagan signed and
every proposal that's followed since
then
is that it starts
by amnestying people
and then promises in the future
cross their heart cross their hearts and
hope to die that they'll enforce the law
so we won't have more illegal
immigration well that's just a lie i
mean it's proven to be a lie it was i i
have to i'm i don't blame the people in
back in 1986 who agreed to it 35 years
ago was the first time we'd done
anything like that
and you know it seemed like it was worth
a try but we've run that experiment if
you will like i said
sorry just before you continue what
exactly was that experiment yeah what
does that mean in 1986 uh after a number
of years of going back and forth
um in you know different legislation in
congress
uh congress passed and president reagan
signed uh what's called the immigration
reform and control act and what that did
was
amnesty
about three million illegal immigrants
is what it ended up being who were
already here
in exchange for
for the first time ever
making it illegal to employ illegal
immigrants because before 1986 the law
specifically said you were allowed to
employ illegal aliens so that's the
magnet that draws people
uh i mean people come because they have
relatives there's a lot of reasons
people come but getting a job is the
chief one is the main thing so if you
can weaken that magnet
um you can reduce illegal immigration
it's never going to go away but you can
make it a much smaller thing well the
problem is the amnesty happened up front
the enforcement never happened it was a
lie to begin with the people who were
pro
uh pro amnesty knew that they were going
to welsh on the deal do everything they
could to prevent to undermine it and we
now have what four times as many illegal
immigrants as we did back then
so
if we're going to talk about amnesty and
i've written about this for years that
i'm open to it but we have to have in
place
up and running
the systems to minimize future
illegal immigration and not to i'll give
you the three-point plan but it's only
i'll
only give you a few seconds on each one
first thing is
we need to have universal use of what's
called the e-verify program it's online
free program run by the government where
when you hire somebody and you take
their info for social security and irs
which you have to do anyway
you just verify it online is that name
real does it match the social security
number do those match the date of birth
is it real now you can still fool it but
it's a sort of basic good governance
thing to make sure that
um you are hiring somebody who's
authorized to work the program exists
about half of people hired new people
hired every year are screened through
the system but the other half aren't and
that's where the illegal aliens are so
that needs to be up and running for
everybody
two
we need a check-in check-out system for
foreign visitors
and i say that because close to half of
new illegal aliens in most years are
people who came in legally they had a
tourist visa student visa whatever it is
and they just never left
and if and we don't know who has left
so if you don't know who has checked out
and gone back to their home country you
don't know who's still here we do the
check in part a lot better than we did
911 really woke people up about that and
congress got serious government got
serious the check in part for foreign
visitors screening them and and and you
know sort of registering the fact that
they've come here is a lot better than
it used to be
the check out part is still kind of a
joke
congress mandated an electronic system
to do that checkout uh 25 years ago it
still hasn't happened they've made some
little attempts at it it's still not in
place so that's number two that has to
be up and running before you can say
okay we fixed the problem now let's
clear the decks and the third thing you
have to have
is sanctuary cities have to be banned by
federal law
because the whole point to a sanctuary
city
is not that it protects immigrants or
something what it does is when local
police arrest somebody
say for dealing drugs or beating up his
girlfriend or driving drunk
everybody that gets arrested their
fingerprints are scanned it's all done
electronically now it's not when i was a
kid they still had on tv you know ink
you take the fingerprints with ink and
paper it's all electronic it's all
scanned now when the fingerprints are
scanned everybody who's arrested it goes
to the fbi and now it goes to dhs that's
relatively new in the past few years so
now homeland security knows when an
illegal immigrant
has been arrested
and what a sanctuary city means is that
that city prohibits
telling
or prohibits cooperating with ice and
handing over this person say he's a
drunk driver
uh but and they arrested him there's no
question about it but they didn't have
good evidence or they've got too many
other cases trial so they're not going
to try it they're going to let him go
well ice
can say hey can you hold on to this guy
for 48 hours so we can get him and
deport him sanctuary cities say
basically give federal government the
finger and say no we're protecting
criminals who are in the united states
so anyway that's the third thing that
has to be
in place not promised but in place
once we do that
i'm open to amnesty it should be quick
rip off the band-aid get it over with i
think there should be a kind of apology
ceremony where the illegal immigrant
says and it should be written in his own
language as well so he understands what
he's saying you know i broke america's
laws by coming here i don't deserve
um to stay but the american people have
you know graced me with this opportunity
and i will you know endeavor the rest of
my life to make myself worthy of it and
we should never talk about there being
illegal aliens not that person being an
illegal alien again but it needs to we
need to have something in place so we
don't have a mass
illegal immigration 10 or 20 years from
now we have another debate about amnesty
okay so one question you said
if you come here you get your passport
stamped you have some sort of visa and
you just stay there's no system in place
that tracks how many days you're here
what nothing that tracks you when you
leave nothing that even i remember
talking to a democratic senator once uh
he was i forget who it was he was from
delaware wasn't joe biden um and he said
when he was i think he was former
governor he said that they had some kind
of program
um when there was some kind of i don't
know whether it was a uh
welfare issue or something but they
would text you
say hey your
you know your hearing date is coming up
or whatever it is in other words we
don't even do that and he was saying
well just doing that would get half the
people who overstay their visas to leave
because we would be telling them hey
uncle sam's paying attention to you they
know you know he knows you're here so
make and you know if we did something
like that should be a text that says
hope you're enjoying your stay in
america you know you've got one week
left on your period of stay is what it's
called when you get at the airport and
they stamp your passport
um make sure you leave on time because
if you don't you know it'll be uh hard
to come back in in the future or
something like that
just doing that
would
in itself reduce visa overstaying
significantly because it would be clear
that somebody is paying attention right
now nobody's paying attention
so what if okay this is coming from a
canadian perspective so we've got the
type of visa where you can basically
come in you can't work but you can stay
for i believe it's up to six months yeah
six within a year yeah usually yeah
yeah um
i assumed because every time you go
they're like have you been here for over
six months or you know how many days
have you been here i assumed that was
some formality that they were just
asking me as like a trick question or
something assuming that there was
something on their computer that said
this person has been here for you know
140 days or something but they're just
looking at stamps and a passport and
nothing's been
basically yeah i mean that's that's
that's what it amounts to i mean i you
know keep telling the truth i encourage
you to tell the truth but but yeah it's
not hard to
fool our immigration system not because
they're stupid but because it's designed
to not be particularly tight or well run
interesting okay another question
sanctuary cities so what do those
those what are those exactly are they
areas of places
well it's usually it's some jurisdiction
it could be a city it could be a county
it could even be a whole state like
california
that with a law in there's different
versions of it but the basic what it
boils down to is that the law
enforcement
in that jurisdiction
is not allowed to cooperate with ice
and now the way this is often presented
is that you know our police aren't
immigration agents that's the federal
government's business yeah okay well
that's true ice doesn't want police
local police
to be walking around the neighborhood
saying you know hey paco where's your
green card police aren't interested in
that
ice doesn't want people to do that
what the the practical effect is that
when the local police arrest somebody
that person
will not face they will protect that
criminal from the immigrant immigration
consequences
if he's for instance a um
you know if he's an illegal immigrant
ice doesn't necessarily know about every
illegal immigrant i mean if you snuck by
the border patrol nobody saw you there's
no record of your ever having been here
if you got arrested
you know
you may not pop up on isis computers but
most illegal immigrants either have come
in legally maybe they got stopped once
by the border patrol thrown back and
then the second time they made it so
that the rec they're in the system in
other words they could have been
deported
formally deported where they go through
the whole court system and if they come
back that that's a felony to come back
after being deported
so that most
illegal immigrants who get arrested have
some kind of paperwork
um some kind of record in dhs's
computers
and what a sanctuary city means
sanctuary policies mean is that those
local or state governments are
protecting illegal immigrants or
protecting immigrants of whatever kind
from the immigration consequences
of their actions and that's just wrong
it has nothing to do with protecting
ordinary people and when you press the
sanctuary city people on this they'll
say yeah nobody should be deported if
you're a murderer you should go to jail
and then when you finish your jail term
you should just be let go and allowed to
stay here because no one should ever be
deported there's even a hashtag not one
more
on twitter which one of the advocacy
groups was pushing pretty actively in
the past and the point being that they
don't think anyone no matter how
criminal they are should be deported
it's not that they're saying criminals
should just always be let go but that if
they're prosecuted they go to jail
when they finish their jail term the way
the law is supposed to work is they're
handed over to homeland security and
they're thrown out of the country but
these sanctuary city folks think that
you know any convicted criminal who
finished serves this term he's an
illegal immigrant he should just be led
to let go to go live as an illegal alien
again rather than be deported
did i did i miss any of the
main arguments is there anything else
you want to talk about before
i ask you where people can find you
online well i think that's the the main
one is that
the problem with immigration is not the
immigrants it's that we have changed
well let me just there's one other sort
of way of illustrating that um i wrote a
book number of years ago making this
argument and when i sent the draft to my
editor the kind of the thing i opened
with
was the metaphor and she made me take
this out so i always added i always
mentioned it just to sort of get back at
her
the metaphor i used was donuts
immigration is like donuts when you're
seven years old donuts are good for you
you need the fat you need the sugar you
your brain is growing your body is
growing it's good for you when you're 57
years old you can't eat donuts like that
anymore there's nothing wrong with the
donuts they're the same donuts maybe
they're jelly donuts instead of crawlers
but they're still just donuts
what's changed is you and you're not
sick you're not broken
your metabolism has changed and so you
need to change your diet and in a sense
this is the same thing where our the
metabolism of the body politic has
changed the immigrants aren't worse
we're not sick or broken we've outgrown
the ability to successfully deal with
mass immigration
and we need to um you know adjust our
policies the
the federal immigration program is just
that a federal government program it's
like farm subsidies or small business
loans or the air force
and
sometimes it may be bigger sometimes it
should be smaller that's what the debate
should be about and not sort of in these
apocalyptic moral terms where anybody
who critiques it is a
you know an evil uh racist xenophobe
blah blah blah you've heard all of that
stuff before um this is a government
policy we need to debate it have a
normal debate i probably won't get
everything i want but that's the way it
is in democratic politics but we need to
debate this rather than make it some
kind of uh you know apocalyptic issue
yes i 100 agree i would say most issues
out there need to be debated otherwise
what are you going to do about it yeah
well exactly yeah no question about it
okay mark where can people find you if
they want to find you online uh the
center for immigration studies i'm the
executive director we're online at
cis.org we have a blog with new postings
every day we also have a weekly podcast
called parsing immigration policy it's
on our website but it's also in all the
usual podcast places and if you have a
taste for snark and sarcasm i'm on
twitter at mark s as in stephen mark s
krikorian
okay thank you very much mark that was
interesting
[Music]
you